you got kind of mad about her taking a
picture with Rick Ross yeah
and communicating with a little baby on
some big bro [__] as an artist wouldn't
it be so annoying well wouldn't it be
smart for her to network with Rick Ross
and little baby for her career hell no
why not because they're not gonna wait
it's not it's not gonna be real
networking you know what I'm saying it's
gonna be like because if I'm managing an
artist and they can
chop it up with Rick Ross or chop it up
a little baby who's one of the hottest
artists in the world I would encourage
that
not when they're trying to [__] that's
what they're trying different so do you
think they're trying to [__]
he says it I just be like I don't
know she she knows she she like to play
around
so like little baby chopping it up with
dude following you big bro or his big
bro which you didn't like obviously I
saw the tweets no that was the that was
the throw-off that's not what he was
telling her